Iran is now reportedly killed 378  protesters in the latest absolutely  brutal Crackdown there and as a result  Iranian World Cup players remained  silent during the national anthem at the  World Cup during their first game that  they played and in the meantime there is  increasing displeasure or lack of  support from many in Iran of the World  Cup team as a show of protest against  what the government is doing even though  the World Cup team itself is also  protesting that very thing we also  learned that Iran planned the kidnapping  and the execution of at least 10 British  citizens over the last year what is  going to be the end game here we don't  know protesters have now set fire to  hominy's ancestral home and this could  go any of a number of directions many of  them brutal and horrifying